Watch me.
Um, is that my buddy Pharmacist
Um,
what's that about? What are you um
about? Root not fruit.
>> Yes, sir. How are you today?
>> I'm doing good. Hey, before I forget, I
have started a newsletter for my
skincare business. So, if anybody wants
to be on the mailing list for my
newsletter, it's just going to be a very
simple newsletter. It's going to be
brain food that I put out every few
days. Send me an email and I'll uh I'll
put you on the mailing list. And there
some Oh, yeah. I'm gonna be on Coast to
Coast tomorrow, too.
coast to coast tomorrow night. So, what
email should they email you at?
>> You know, that's a good question. I've
been given my personal email out. Do you
have another email address for me?
>> Can you set me up with an email address?
>> A root note email address.
>> Yeah, you do have a rootnfruit email
address, but let's uh let's let's folks
email questions
questions at dailywithdoc.com and and
we'll we'll get them to you. How about
that? That's good. That's good. It goes
It goes out every couple days. It's just
It's just me. Just my random thoughts
are real short. Couple hundred words.
Three two to 300, excuse me, two to 300
words. But they're all things that I
find interesting and hopefully you will
find interesting as well.
>> Well, we we we always find you
interesting.
>> Okay. Um, and I certainly have gotten a
good number. Well, I got a a couple of
questions in uh that we need to address.
And I need to I'm just I just need to
make sure that we get uh all of our
folks who need to be here on uh and Ruth
Ellen is helping us as usual
uh running the ship and and and never
gets the credit she deserves because
it's in the background. But uh
pharmacist Ben what?
>> Don't mess with Ruth Ellen.
No,
>> do not mess with Ruth Ellen Sanchez.
That is one badass woman.
>> Don't Don't be cracking jokes when Ruth
Ellen's trying to be serious.
>> No, I'm serious. She's a badass. She's
from Bucks County.
>> Yeah,
>> mess around in Bucks County. They don't
play.
>> That's the meth capital. Meth capital of
the world.
>> Is it really?
>> Are they tough in Bucks County?
>> They are tough, man.
>> Oh, really?
>> Wow.
>> Okay. Oh,
>> Ruth Ellen. Did you grow up there, Ruth
Ellen, or you just live there now?
>> Ruth Ellen's from California, man.
>> Oh, yeah. She lives in Bucks County. I
think she lives in Bucks County.
>> Although, she she rolled with the
toughest people in California, too.
>> She's a she's a badass.
>> Remain nameless.
>> Ruth, look at that sweet, sweet face.
You would never know that's a badass
mama.
>> Yeah.
>> Have you ever seen Ruth Ellen's tats?
>> Serious.
>> Everybody can see my tats right now.
Yeah. Yeah, she's got no tats, man. Stop
it. Stop getting scared. Although, they
should be scared.
There just just the opposite.
>> Look how sweet her face is. Don't be
fooled by that sweet face.
>> Yeah, don't be fooled.
>> Do not be fooled.
>> It's an angel in disguise.
>> Have you?
>> Yes.
>> Have you ever been Have you ever been on
the other end of that other end of those
fangs there?
>> Talk to me. Oh, yeah. Weekly.
>> I have.
>> All right. Have a good show you guys.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Pharmacist Ben, you
>> had mentioned recently you were talking
about a um article dealing with colon
cancer.
>> You were going to send that to me
>> happening to people younger.
>> Yeah, I thought that was really
interesting because nobody could figure
out why.
What could it be? Why would colon cancer
be happening in people younger and
younger? Why? I can't imagine why
doctors are mystified.
What could possibly be causing the
increased rate in food cancer, which is
what colon cancer is? What do you
suppose? Could it be the food?
Could it be the foe? You think the
people were eating?
>> Yeah, they did. They did kind of mention
a couple things including uh processed
foods being
uh a potential
>> Oh, you think
>> you think it's the the stuff we're
eating, especially the the meats, the
lunchables. That's that's what really
that'll fuel colon cancer like nobody's
business. the Lunchables, the the uh the
foods that have the nitrates in them.
Nitrates are nitrates.
>> Doc always says no processed meats.
>> No processed meats. They're like among
the worst foods a human being can eat
are processed meats, hot dogs and such.
Bologna,
>> bacon.
>> Bacon is one of the worst. It may be the
worst. For the life of me, I do not
understand the fascination with bacon.
I've had when I was a kid, I never ate
bacon and then I had it a few times.
It's just I find it gross. Am I missing
something? It's like fat and salt and
oily and what? There's no meat in it.
What What's the thing about bacon?
>> I I think it's that whole thing that you
talk about or we have
>> salt and the fat. The combination of
salt and fat.
>> Salt and fat. Yeah,
>> salt and fat. Yeah, maybe. But I'll tell
you what, I I don't get that that whole,
you know, they got bacon ice cream and
bacon peanut butter and bacon chocolate
and you know, bacon on all kinds of
stuff. Put bacon
>> double bacon burger.
>> Double bacon burger. Come on. They
actually call them a coronary. There's
one company that calls it a coronary
coronary burger. How could you say that?
You know,
>> I don't know. Yeah, I've never had a
heart attack, but I've seen people have
had heart attacks and
can you imagine that? What that would
feel like
having a heart attack? Oh my god, that's
your heart. Your poor heart. And I love
that when they say your heart attack,
like your heart attacked you. No, you
attacked your heart. Your heart didn't
attack you. We're attacking our heart
with bacon. If you do like bacon, after
you're done with your bacon, get
yourself some
Youngevity Healthy Brain and Heart Pack.
The nutrients in the Healthy Brain and
Heart Pack will mitigate the damage from
the bacon, at least the cardiovascular
damage. Do you know after every
cigarette you smoke, if you gargle with
Beyond Taggy Tangerine, like like swish
it in your mouth, you will neutralize
the toxins or partially anyway,
neutralize the toxins from the cigarette
smoke,
>> like partially
>> partially probably I don't know about to
what degree, but you'll partially do it.
And that's a really important point.
Nutrients can allow nutritional
supplementation, I should say, can allow
you to get away with things or or at
least make it easier to get away with
things, if not allow you to totally get
away with things.
You know, so what can we do to help
these young um you know uh folks uh
demographic disparity disparities? The
spike is particularly profound among
Hispanic and white populations and not
notably prevalent in the western US
among 35 to 44 year olds.
>> What do you I'm not sure what your
question is. This is so these are the
plate. How do we help folks deal with
this colurectal cancer surge in 35 to 44
year olds and even even younger three
>> yeah there healthy digestion pack
ultimate enzymes with meals
um stay away from
certain foods specifically processed
foods preserved foods Um
high lots of meat
depending on the meat meat you know meat
like regular meat can have hormones in
it that can disturb the gut microbiome
antibiotics in it that can disturb the
gut microbiome if you have slow motility
the meat can putrify. Can you you know
that word putrify? You don't want to
hear that when it comes to your
intestine. It will actually, you know,
there's a chemical called putricine,
a molecule called putricine that's
produced for from putrifying meat.
>> And you don't want
>> you It's not used for anything. It's a
waste product. It's a waste product from
rotting meat. It's one of the reasons
rotting meat has a certain smell that it
has. Repulsive smell, by the way. Can
you imagine what your intestine looks
like after you eat a hamburger?
Like the
>> Oh god, the bloop.
Oh god. Just think of the last time you
vomited. Most of that was from your
intestine.
>> Wait, the last time Last time you you
bought a You never You You don't eat a
hamburger?
>> The last time I had a hamburger was many
years like No, I've had hamburger. But
like fast food hamburger, you mean?
>> Hamburger in general?
>> Oh, yeah. I have I have ham I eat
hamburger meat. I make sloppy joe's or
I'll make beans. I'll take onions, grill
up some or um fry up some onions in
butter and or coconut butter usually and
then uh and then maybe green pepper or
red pepper. I don't like the red ones, I
think, a little bit better. More vitamin
C. Uh and then um and then I'll throw in
some ground beef, 8020,
and just, you know, fry it up. And then
throw in some beans and throw in some
tomato sauce and a bunch of spices. And
then I'll eat that for a couple days.
>> So you're not a 9010 guy because you
want the fat?
>> No, I'm more like 8020. Sometimes 9010,
but more like 8020, but yeah, I'll do
that. The last time I had a fast food
hamburger though was I'll never forget
it because it's probably the last one
I'll eat was at Wendy's in the St. uh
Salt Lake City airport. I had it and it
was so gross and it was so salty and it
was so like like particly I I never had
it. I never ate another one again, you
know. But when I was a kid, you know,
fast food in a lot of ways is made for
kids. You know that um you know when you
get a McDonald's hamburger, how it's
wrapped and then you unwrap it,
>> present.
>> Looks like a present, right? It has all
of the the brain signals of Christmas.
Yay. You know, and look at the little
look at my gift. Look at my little
jackpot in there. You know, my hamburger
jackpot. And so they make it, they
create the whole scenery around it, you
know, but if you just looked at the
hamburger without the bun and without
the stuff on top of it, that little
patty thing, without without any of the
accutrants, you know, you wouldn't eat
that. You wouldn't eat that in a million
years. Even unless you're in jail,
unless you're in prison,
>> they should make you they should make
you put it together yourself.
>> You wouldn't eat it.
>> Yeah. Imagine next time go just spend a
dollar on a I don't even know how much
they are anymore. Probably a dollar or
something. $2. Get get a McDonald's
hamburger, take the bun off and all the
stuff off and just look at that thing
and then put it in your closet. Put it
in your put it in a box in your closet
and then check on it 20 years later.
It'll be exactly the same
not have changed.
>> I don't know how. And then we wonder why
colon cancer is, you know, cancer.
>> The healthy digestion pack and extra uh
extra ultimate enzymes.
enzymes, apple cider vinegar with your
meal.
>> Apple cider vinegar or um you know, we
haven't talked, we don't really talk
about the betane,
>> you know, the the betane hydrochloride,
>> hl. Uhhuh.
>> Yeah. Betane HCL. So, what do you tell
me you I mean, you're the smartest guy
in longevity. No lie.
>> No lie. You are. Tell me about betane
HCL from your perspective.
>> I don't I don't I don't know. I don't
know much about it. All all I can
imagine it does is just break things
down,
>> right? It's a source of HCL,
hydrochloric acid. HCL is hydrochloric
acid, right? So betane HCL is a source
of hydrochloric acid. So it helps not
just it probably a little bit break
things down, but really it activates the
enzymes. Enzy,
excuse me, enzymes in um digestive
enzymes are activated by acid. If you're
not producing stomach acid, and many
people aren't, or at least not
sufficient stomach acid, you're not
going to activate your enzymes.
Does that make sense? You follow me? So,
activation of the enzymes requires low
pH. And that's why apple cider vinegar
or beyond tangy tangerine for that
matter or aloe vera or something a low
pH beverage with your enzymes and with
your meals will support digestion. Okay,
before you move on, aloe vera
seems very
>> it's about pH4ish.
You know, it's interesting that you say
that because whatever form we get aloe
vera, even if you even if you cut open a
plant, it appears to be innocuous where
it appears to be like if I had to guess,
I would have think that aloe vera was a
seven because it appears to be very
balanced. Whereas a lemon,
>> let me tell you why it's let me tell you
what what the kind of trick is. Why it
appears balanced and it's really
sitting. It's got the same pH as your
skin.
So, it's not that it's seven, which
would be neutral. It's that it's
equivalent to your skin. So, you don't
feel it. You can only feel things that
are different from your skin pH. If it's
the same in the same ballpark as your
skin, you're not going to feel it. But
your skin has a pH of about four to
five. And aloe vera has a pH of about
four to five. So, it's it's skin
friendly, skin compatible, but in the
scheme of things, it's a little acidic.
not tremendously acidic, but a little
bit acidic. Apple cider vinegar is a
little bit more acidic. It's about 10
times more acidic. And then um betane
HCL, I'm not exactly sure the acid level
of that, so I can't speak to it, but it
is hydrochloric acid. And that's the
acid that is um that's that's the acid
it's in your stomach. But here's what's
cool about betane HCL.
that why I think it warrants a
discussion not because of the HCL
but because of the betane.
The betane
is a a um uh a synonym I guess it's
another way of saying the chemical which
is trithyl
glycine.
Betane is trimethyl. We call it betane
but it's really trimethly.
So what does trimethlycine mean in your
lay person mind? What would you think of
when you hear trimethyl glycine?
>> Glycine with three methyl groups,
>> right? Trimethaglycine. Exactly. So why
is that important? Well, methyl is
methylation. You know how people are
always complaining about methylation.
Oh, I've got MTHFR. I can't methylate. I
need methylate. Here's your methylating
agent.
Trimethyl glycine or betane is a
methylating agent. It's got three
methals in there. And glycine is one of
the most underappreciated amino acids.
It's critical for the production of
connective tissue and it's a major detox
amino acid. So you're taking your betane
HCL for acidifying your uh your um uh
your the contents of your stomach and
activating enzymes, but you're getting
methylation
which everybody can use a little bit
more of. And you're getting glycine,
which is a very important fundamental
amino acid that many people are
deficient in for your bones, for
wrinkles, for your blood vessels, and
for detoxification.
I bet you never I bet nobody ever told
you that.
>> No, of course not. No, no one. That's
not that is not a dinner table
conversation typically. Um
>> it should be
>> an pharmacist Ben just the last point
about this article what may I you know
you seem to have a different perspective
when it comes to the way they word
things but it says while there's no
single cause researchers expect a
combination of lifestyle factors
starting in childhood including obesity
sedentary behavior ultrarocessed foods
foods in dietdriven gut dispiosis.
>> Where who's told you that? I say that
all the time.
>> All the time. I talk about that. I'm not
making it up. All the time. And And it's
kind of no-brainer. Obviously, what can
happen to your intestine unless
something gets into your intestine,
>> right? It's got to be something that's
getting into your intestine. It's not
something that's getting into your hand.
It's not something that's getting into
your nostril. It's got to be something
that's getting into your intestine. It's
an intestinal problem. Hello. And then
you throw in you add in factor in what
we're eating. So of course you're going
to have problems. Of course you're the
less you eat the longer you live
especially the kind of food we eat.
Especially the kind of food we eat uh in
the 21st century in the US of A.
>> That is unfortunate. Pharmacist Ben. Uh
so I took my dad to a place uh called
the doctor the other day.
>> Okay. What was what was his issue?
>> Well, he's
What's his issue? His issue is he
doesn't listen to his son.
>> How old is he? Your dad?
>> Uh
>> young?
>> Yeah. My dad used to run uh you know uh
but but but back in the day or back in
the early 90s he had the meniscus
surgery and they took out the meniscus
apparently.
Uh so now he's dealing with
>> his knee his knee
>> both knees dealing with the bone on
bone.
>> Oh no.
>> Uh with the metabolic syndrome, you
know. So
>> Oh no. Is he overweight?
>> Not anymore.
>> What do you mean?
>> He's pretty much underweight in my
opinion. I'm looking at him. He looks
like skin and bones.
>> Oh my gosh. He's frail.
>> And um
I'm just trying to, you know, he is
willing to take pills, but he won't do
um tangy tangerine because it interferes
with his diet coke. And he
>> Come on. Come on. Are you serious?
>> Serious.
>> He won't do BTT.
>> He won't do He won't do BTT because it
interferes with his diet coke and unlike
taste. He won't do be nothing liquid.
Won't do Beyond Osteo.
>> Why? He doesn't like the taste.
>> You know, one time he said, "I did the
Beyond Osteo and my blood pressure
dropped so much." And I said, "Well,
then you need less blood pressure
medication." But yeah,
>> he was taking blood pressure medication
and Beyond Osteo. So instead of lowering
the blood pressure medication, he
stopped taking the beyond osteo
beyond.
>> I got it. That's a tough one to deal
with there.
>> Had him take m It's probably the
magnesium in the beyond osteo. Get him
on some magnesium.
>> The cow mag.
>> Yeah, get him on the cow mag.
>> Well, cow mag
>> osteo mag. Get them on osteo mag.
>> Osteo mag.
>> Yeah, get them on the osteo mag. I think
there's vitamin D in there, too. Vitamin
D will help also.
>> Yeah, get them on vitamin D or get them
out in the sun.
>> Maybe Key and Ruth Ellen can help us
with a protocol for my dad that we can
to help him out because uh
>> why don't get your dad on. Get your dad
on the air.
I want to see your dad. I'm gonna give
him a hard time.
>> Yeah. You know what? That that would be
that would be great. Um, well,
>> actually, I was going to compliment him
for you, if you must know.
>> You know, man,
>> I'm gonna say you did a heck of a job
with that young man.
>> Young AJ,
>> you're very gracious. I hope never to
disappoint you.
>> I'm just I'm just telling like it is.
>> We have uh Stacy emailed us in
uh and given our topic tonight. Uh are
colonoscopies safe? Is Colag Guard a
good alternative?
>> Colag Guard is just for people who are
predisposed to having colon cancer. It's
not for everybody. And then um are
colonoscopies safe
for the most part, but it's not unheard
of to have perforations and that's a
terrible thing in the colon. So, for the
most part, they're safe though. And
given that's really the only way to know
if you have, you know, a growth in
there, and many people do, it's probably
a good idea to have them done once in a
while.
>> Okay. Pharmacist Ben, is there anything
you can do to coat your gut to help
yourself uh if you're going to have a
colonoscopy
>> to coat your gut? I don't think you want
it coated to
>> protect it from
>> from the from the scope. Yeah. From the
scoper. Um,
no. But there are things
>> aloe or something.
>> Yeah, I was going to say there are
things you could do that are very
important for gut health. Things like
aloe, slimy things,
aloe, a lot of herbs like mow or colts
foot or mullen. These are herbs that
have a slimy quality to them. Algaee's,
fucoidin,
um, uh, what else here? Slum, mushroom,
things that have lots of, uh,
polysaccharides.
Polysaccharides absorb water and form
gels or slimes. And so these gels or
slimes can have really interesting
protective benefits for the intestine
and they're not it's not a bad idea to
use them. But I don't think I don't
think it's going to if the scope is
pretty invasive. I mean, you're sticking
something in there that's you know a
scope small.
>> I hear I hear it's a real pain in the
ass.
>> Oh no. Come on.
Come on. I can't believe you.
So, so slim slim yourself up.
>> Slime. Slime is one of the best things
you could do to get rid of things.
That's how the body gets rid of
bacteria. It slimes it away. Like like
uh like Ghostbusters.
>> Remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> Forget.
>> How could you forget?
>> Ghostbusters,
>> you know. But pharmacist Ben, uh it's
interesting that you say that a
colonoscopy is the only way. I can't
imagine that's the only way for people
to make that determined determin
>> um but I had a person who had uh fought
um digestive issues for a long time and
I can't remember if she had a
gallbladder or not but oh no she had
yeah she had a gallbladder at the time
and she was dealing with bad uh
digestive issues and one of the things
that I got her on was the Z radical
Yep.
>> She started feeling a lot better. Tons
better.
>> That's the slime.
>> And she went to the doctor and the
doctor said, "Well, we got to do a
scope."
>> And they scoped her.
She got an infection that wind up taking
out her gallbladder.
>> Oh my god.
>> And it was And she was almost crying.
She's like, "AJ,
you put the scope down your throat."
So great. Blah blah blah.
>> Ah, it's terrible.
>> So yeah, I don't I don't not a fan of
invasive.
>> I I you know, it's a little it's a
little thing. It's not a big camera or
the scope, but yeah, I'm not a Yeah,
I've never had one personally,
so I don't know. I mean, I They want me
They want you to have one after age 50.
I think it's every year every every
other year.
I I never I never I haven't done it,
but that's just me. I'm not recommending
everybody.
>> Well, you know, you got our good friend
Kenya is um on uh
>> I always get Kenya mixed up with her
sister. Her what's her sister's name?
>> Kiana.
>> Kiana. I spoke to Kiana on Saturday.
>> You did?
>> I did speak to Kiana. Kiana's still
having some of those issues.
um uh that she had before. So, we're
gonna we're going to really we're going
to dial dial down or drill down on what
she's eating because she's still having
those issues.
>> Yeah. But she also needs to take um the
volume of product. I would think that
you know um
>> Well, you're working with her, right?
>> Well, until she started talking to you,
but but
>> she No, I only talked to her once.
>> Well, I'm just joking. But and uh I
guess I could follow up with people much
better than I do. I really don't really
>> I only talked to her I talked to her
that one time
>> but from my but from my recollection uh
the volume of product you know uh it
it's it's kind of like you make you make
a you make a suggestion on how to make
um a vanilla soule cake and if you don't
use all the components it's not a
vanilla soule cake. I don't know. Do
vanilla soule cakes exist?
>> I I don't know. But I know your point.
>> Yeah.
>> If you want a vanilla soule cake, you
got to have all the ingredients to make
a vanilla soule cake, whatever that is.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. No, your point's well taken. You
can't just have like, oh, I'm going to
make a vanilla soule cake and not not
put any of the soule in it.
>> Mhm.
>> Or the vanilla,
right? It's critical. The usual methods
using scopes. He favors stool testing.
The problem with stool testing is that's
not telling you exactly what's happening
in the colon, but it's still a sec. I
could see that. Who Who wrote that?
Dong. Who's Dong? Di Long.
>> Um uh a a very uh consistent viewer.
>> That's good. That That's good. I think
that's a good point. Is a is a um is
like a CAT scan or some kind of
ultrasound device, something like that.
Uh, Key says, "A colonoscopy resulted in
a flesheating bacteria at the largest
hospital in Cleveland."
>> Yeah, it it just doesn't seem
>> like you want to poke poke around in
there.
>> Yeah. Okay. If I can't take gluca gel
due to the shellfish.
>> Oh, that's a myth. It's a myth. First of
all, um, shellfish allergies
are a result of histamine,
so-called shellfish allergies. There's
also protein in shellfish sometimes
people can react to. That's not in
glucosamine. Glucosamine is glucosamine.
It's not. Nobody's allergic to
glucosamine. There's no shellfish in
glucosamine. That being said, there is
the CYA
aspect and that's that you have to for
legal reasons they just have to say in
case in the factory there was some
contamination. But we do have a gluc we
do I think there's a seafood free
glucosamine, isn't there? Uh Ruth Ellen
just said that the liquid gluca gel is
shellfish free.
>> They're all shellfish free, but there
might be some contaminants is the
thinking.
>> Some shellfish contaminants in the
factory. You know, some of the
glucosamine have a little contaminant.
It's very unlikely.
>> And glucosamine is unbelievably
valuable. It's just a stupendously
valuable supplement. And and you know, I
was reading an article. Can I do a quick
article read here?
>> Uh, yes. But I have a quick point to
make about what you just said. Okay.
because and I wasn't going to bring it
up, but there was a comment in one of
your videos from from before and you
mentioned the shellfish allergy and uh
and and it and the comment was a guy
saying I was excited to hear from Ben,
but he said that the shellfish allergy
is due to protein and he didn't mention
uh iodine. He said the iodine is the
reason that people have the shellfish
allergy. What is Ben talking about? Does
he even know what he's saying? That
type.
>> Does that person really say that?
>> Yeah, pretty much.
>> It's not the It's not the iodine. Put
that person on. Let's talk. There's a
protein in shellfish. A and shellfish
also trigger histamine response. Can
trigger histamine response. And so often
times that histamine response is um is
mistaken for an like a an allergic
reaction to the shellfish. Now is he
saying people are allergic to iodine? Is
that what he's saying?
>> Uh he's saying that iodine is the reason
that's giving the people that's giving
people problem.
>> So he's saying people have an allergic
reaction to iodine.
>> He is. Yes.
>> Well, does that make sense to anybody
who understands the nature of essential
nutrition?
>> Well, I mean, you know, um
>> Yeah. No, think about it. If you're if
you die without iodine, if you can't run
your body without iodine, and iodine is
very powerful.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, it's an incredibly powerful element.
Um, and iodine deficiency is a really
serious problem around the world. Um,
how could you be allergic to iodine?
Now, there may be forms of iodine that
he's thinking of. I I would I guess, but
no, iodine is an essential nutrient.
Well,
>> so maybe maybe it's some kind of
iodinated protein he's talking about.
Typically allergies only happen to
protein.
>> Do you get that?
>> So you have to you have to have
something has to have a protein nature
to trigger um to trigger a allergic
reaction. An iodine an allergy to
straight iodine is it's like impossible
because it's an essential nutrient. How
could it be? iodine containing molecule
or compounds.
You can't have an allergy and I've heard
of allergies to dyes sometimes or
aneseptics, povone iodine and that kind
of thing. But you can't be allergic to
an essential nutrient. I hear sometimes
people say they're allergic to vitamin
C. You know, you can't be allergic. That
doesn't make sense. These are biological
possibilities.
Does it you understand what I'm saying?
>> 155%.
>> So I don't know what this gentle was
talking about unless I'm missing
something. Well, we'll invite him on one
day.
>> Yes. Is he a regular?
>> No, he caught a replay.
>> Okay. So, he's not on regularly.
>> I don't know. It's the first time I've
seen his name, but you know, the show is
growing. You're you're you're growing
and
>> almost as fast as your hair is growing
back after that slick cut.
>> I told you grow back fast.
>> So, so um is the show are we getting
more listeners?
>> Oh, yeah. We get a steady like a new
especially on Rumble, a new follower
every day. Uh, and on uh YouTube, we
probably are growing a bit as well. So,
>> well, now we're attracting people. What
do they call them? Trolls. They're
attacking us.
>> Oh, no. We We got rid of the trolls. The
trolls.
>> No, this guy, he sounds like a little
bit of a troll, but I maybe he's not.
I'm just kidding.
>> I I No, I think he was being sincere.
>> Maybe he is. But there's a there is a
protein in shellfish. It's involved with
the muscle. That is the assumed to be
the cause. I don't know if it's ever
been shown definitively, but it's
assumed to be the cause of shelfish
allergy. Also, histamine, uh, a
histamine response sometimes gets gets
kind of confused or conflated with, um,
a true shelfish allergy. Iodine, that
doesn't make sense to me.
>> Okay. So, what's this article you were
talking about
>> mentioning you want to share?
>> Yeah, there's a really interesting
article. Let me find it. Why don't you
Why don't you um tap dance a little bit
for us here?
>> Yes. And everybody, don't forget to go
to rootnotfruit.com
and dailywithdocam.com
and get yourselves more uh uh informed
on some of the things that we talk about
at rootnfruit.com. You can actually uh
look at some of Ben's protocols that
might be relevant to you. And we
appreciate everyone who is with us,
including Barbara and Mary
and uh Lit and Bruce of course and
Wyoming Annie and everyone else
>> Annie
>> and everyone else who's watching with us
um
Kenya and everyone else and watching us
with us on Rumble. Uh we appreciate you
all. just do us a favor and spread the
word. And I cannot forget our buddy here
uh Notorious Steph
Lit
uh
and Keely and and because I will forget
at the end of the show can't do this
show without Rudellan and I really
appreciate you and Becca Dukes for even
uh making
>> for even talking to us
>> even making Yeah. Making
>> even talking to us just because, you
know, even just having just looking at
us.
>> I mean, AJ especially, he AJ can't get
any woman to look at him.
>> Hard to look at. Yes. Yes.
>> Teasing you. Thank you. We appreciate
you, Ruth Ellen. And and
>> All right. What What you got for an
article, sir?
>> Okay. Yeah. This was interesting to me.
So, um, check this out. Americans
popping
more supplements than ever, but fewer
multivitamins.
In other words, they're taking co
Americans are taking collagen,
elderberry, probiotics, bilberry,
ashwagandha, all these kind of
fancymancy specialty products, but
they're not taking the essential
nutrients. And I thought that was
important because it it demonstrates how
we really don't understand culturally,
not present company excluded of course,
culturally what essential nutrients
really are, right? If we can consider
and and sometimes you'll hear people
say, "Oh, I take vitamins." And what do
they mean by that? Do they mean they
take vitamins or do they mean they take
supplements?
You know, we kind of lump these things,
all these words together. Essential
nutrients are singularly important.
They're unicorns. They stand out in
importance because of the word
essential. What does the word essential
mean?
>> It means it's something we need. We
don't have it. We break down. Our body
can't make it on its own. And
ultimately, if we don't have it, we die.
>> Yes. But basically, that's it. Air is
essential. You don't have to say the
part we we can't make it on our own.
Just say without it, you die. That's
what an essential nutrient is. Like air.
Air is an essential nutrient. Without
air you die. So these aren't optional.
The problem is this is where it becomes
confusing and a little bit easy to not
easy to blow off easy to ignore.
Nobody has zero nutrients. Nobody has
zero essential nutrients. Everybody's
going to have a little tiny bit of
essential nutrient. So nobody's going to
die. But the problem is they're not
going to be maximally healthy. So you're
right. Without an essential nutrient,
without vitamin C, without nasin,
without zinc, without iodine, whatever
it is, you will die. That's the
definition of essential nutrient. But
nobody has zero. You're always going to
have a trace amount at the very least.
So, because you don't die, people say,
"Well, I'm okay." But no, you're leaving
maximum health on the table. And that's
that's a subtle point. You know, people
will think, "Oh, I'm not dead. I'm a
fine. I can do whatever I want to do."
But you're not maximally healthy. You're
leaving health on the table when you
don't maximize these nutrients. And and
one of the things about maximizing and
and by maximizing, we mean taking them
in addition to foods, taking
concentrated zinc, 50 milligrams a day
of zinc or or whatever, 2,000 milligrams
a day of vitamin C, whatever you decide
to take. The reason these kinds of doses
are so important, number one, because it
kind of guarantees that that you'll get
enough considering absorption issues and
um and and dirty blood and and digestive
issues, etc. So, taking high
concentrations assures that you're going
to get something. So, if you only get
10%, just picking a number here, if you
only get 10% of your nutritional
supplement into your system into cells,
I um under ideal circumstances, and you
take two and you take 200 milligrams,
you're only going to get what? 20
milligrams. But if you get 10% of 2,000
milligrams, now you're going to get 200
milligrams. So, mega doses is a good way
to make sure at like an insurance
policy, you get the concentrations you
need.
Even more so
when you take a high concentration of
something, you leverage something called
fix law. F I ke or f I cs. No e. Fix
law. Fix law is named after guess who?
Robert Thick. I was
called fix law.
>> It's not a It's not a trick question.
Fix law. Robert Fick. He came up with
Fick's law. That's also known as the law
of diffusion. And the law of diffusion
says if you take a cup and you put a
membrane in the middle of it, right? You
put a cheesecloth or parchment or some
kind of membrane, right? And you put a
bunch of salt on the left hand side.
Eventually the salt will go to the right
hand side until both sides are equal.
Make sense? Everything in nature wants
to equilibrate. So when you have a lot
on one side and nothing on the other
side, the law of diffusion will support
the crossing across the membrane. So how
does what does this have to do with mega
dosing with nutritional supplements? If
you put a lot of nutritional supplements
on the outside of your intestinal
membrane through mega dosing beyond
tangy tangerines, say you're going to
force
that stuff across the membrane via fixed
law, via the law of diffusion. Make
sense? In other words, it's a way of
driving the stuff across the membrane.
So, high doses of a supplement not only
are important as an insurance policy to
make sure you're getting what you need,
but also because it helps you push via
this law of diffusion from your
intestine into your blood and ultimately
from your blood into a cell.
>> Make sense?
>> That's fant that's
>> why you want these high concentrations.
>> I use this in my skincare by the way. In
my skincare products, I use high
concentrations of nutrients so that when
you put on your skin via fix law, the
law of diffusion, it'll get pushed
across the stratum corneium into the
epidermis and the dermis where the
living cells are. You know, most
skincare products sit on the surface of
the skin. They're not going to really do
much. The surface of the skin is dead.
You know, you go out and you spend
whatever $100, under $20, $200 on your
fancy schmancy, you know, moisturizer
that this whatever Kaye B say.
>> Yeah. whatever Lar Ro Pose or Haley
Bieber or whatever it is you put on your
skin. Hey, what do you got? Soft dead
skin. Congratulations. That's what you
want for your $200 an ounce. Haley
Bieber, Kaye Kesha, whatever the heck.
What's her name? Kardashian. Kardashian
cream.
>> Kay Bieber is cute.
>> I'm not talking about your your
pedophile predelection.
>> She's married to She's married.
Oh, I thought she was a kid. I
>> No, she's a model. You see her on the
billboards?
>> Oh, didn't she used to be a kid? Wasn't
she famous when she was a kid?
>> Her father's famous. I forget who her
father is.
>> It's a Baldwin. Her father's a Baldwin,
I think.
>> Yeah, that's that's who it is.
>> You know, you ever seen the Baldwins
around NYC?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Cruising around.
>> I've seen the the less famous Baldwin a
bunch of times.
>> Oh, yeah. The the Billy
>> and the more famous one once or twice.
>> You have? Huh? Yeah. They're total New
Yorkers, huh?
Bill. Billy is the less famous one,
right? Billy Baldwin.
>> Yeah, I I've seen him a bunch of times.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. The other one's the famous one.
>> Yeah. Alec,
>> what was that movie with Michael Keaton?
Uh, where he played this crazy What the
heck was that movie? It was like a scary
Tim Burton movie. I forgot what
that was. All right, never mind. Anybody
know what that movie was with Michael
Keaton where he plays this crazy guy?
Okay. Well, uh,
>> this crazy crazy ghost guy. He's like a
ghost and Michael Keaton is a ghost and
Alec Alec and his wife forgot who his
wife was, they die and uh, they meet
this. It's a great movie.
>> Okay, but back to your point again.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, I understand your point because you
you illustrated it with the subclinical
scurvy.
>> Yes.
>> Idea. So, so to understand that you
gotta supplement in in larger doses
because all a lot of us maybe all of us
can suffer from a form of subclinical
scurvy. Uh not having enough vitamin.
>> What's the other name for subclinical
scurvy?
>> Uh let's see.
>> Do you remember?
>> Let's see. Um,
>> I mean besides MBFA, I'm trying to think
what it could be. Uh, let's
>> subclinical scurvies is another name for
aging.
>> Aging. Okay.
>> Aging. Aging. The signs of aging are
very similar to the signs of scurvy. But
aging won't aging will kill you
eventually, but not won't kill you like
scr Oh. Um, Beetlejuice.
Beetlejuice was the name of the movie.
Did you ever see that movie?
Say it one more time.
>> Beetlejuice.
>> Oh, you said it three times. He's gonna
come now.
>> Oh, that's right. That's right. That's
right. That's right. You have seen it
then.
>> Yes, I've seen
>> Jesus. Wasn't that a good movie?
>> Well, I I have seen parts of it.
>> Okay. It's a really good movie. Anyway,
um so uh aging, the signs of aging, the
thinning skin, the thinning bones, the
general thinning is really it's a
thinning disease. Your body thins, the
connective tissue thins uh and it tears
and it breaks. All that's aging. Aging
is a connective tissue driven
condition. I don't want to say disease
condition. Let me say that again. That's
really important. Aging is largely
connective tissue driven. Deterioration
of connective tissue and that's what
scurvy is. The building the connective
tissue is the key. The key and that's
the healthy bone and joint pack by the
way.
>> The healthy bone and joint pack is your
connective tissue is for connective
tissue building.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. we um
you know the more I'm glad to know you
because uh I'm really uh coming to grips
with the importance of vitamin C. Um I
mean obviously all the other nutrients
that are essential or
>> they're all important but I always say
whenever I think of vitamin C I think of
Babe Ruth and other baseball players.
Like everybody knows Babe Ruth Babe Ruth
there's baseball players and then
there's Babe Ruth. In the future, it'll
be Showi Otani. But now, for now, it's
Babe Ruth. Show is ridiculous.
>> He's got he's gota he's got
>> is ridiculous.
>> Yeah, he's he's got to become American
citizen for him to get there.
>> You think? Okay. But you know what I'm
saying? Even non-fans know who Babe Ruth
was. You have to be a B. He's transcends
the sport,
>> right?
>> Michael Jordan.
>> No, your average person's not a fan is
gonna know Michael Jordan probably.
>> Really? I would think if you somebody
who wasn't a basketball fan, you know,
my mom wouldn't know who Michael Jordan
was. She sure would know Babe she would
know Babe Ruth.
>> You know, Babe Ruth is in the he's in
the cultural pantheon. Michael Jordan's
not in the cultural pantheon yet.
There's no c they name a candy bar after
Bab after Michael Jordan. Michael
>> after him.
>> What a sneaker. Yeah, that's true. But I
mean, sneakers are for athletes. Candy
bars are for everybody.
>> Babe Ruth transcends that. He transcends
the sport. Vitamin C transcends the
nutrient. I always think of that when I
think of vitamin C. It's it's
transcendent.
It's not like an ordinary vitamin in the
sense that it's so fundamental. It's so
fundamental that other animals make
their own.
>> So, so vitamin C, yes, that's amazing to
learn from.
>> And they make more when they're the more
stress they're under, the more they
make. It's a coping vitamin. It helps us
cope. It helps us deal with life. It
helps us repair the inevitable damages
that occur to that occur in life. It's
just so so so valuable. The problem is
sometimes when you hear something over
and over again, you don't take it as
seriously. It kind of becomes, you know,
yeah, I know about vitamin C, but you
don't really know about vitamin C. It's
just that important. And it's cheap and
it's easy. Uh it's completely non-toxic
and it's incredibly incredibly
incredibly effective for building not
just for building connective. You can't
build connective tissue without it.
So I am a huge fan of
>> vitamin C is the babe Ruth. What's the
ple?
>> I I don't know much about soccer so I
can't tell you but
>> you know who ple is?
>> Well yeah
>> I don't know anything about soccer
either
>> but I know who ple.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay. I wonder how many of
our listeners have heard of Ple.
>> Everybody's heard.
>> Probably not. You know, we we're sports
fans.
>> Okay, we need we need a we need a poll,
folks. How many people just put a one if
you've heard of PLE, a two if you've
never heard of PLE? So, uh Key had a
question uh sent to her by a listener.
Can you explain the correlation of
disease given pH in all areas of the
body, i.e. stomach,
>> urine? Yes, they're all basically going
to be um slightly alkaline
to certain extent. I think I think urine
might be a little bit less alkaline,
maybe a little more acid, but they're
all going to be slightly alkaline once
they run into acid. Uh and by the pH
scale goes from 0 to 14. Seven is a
neutral. The blood pH is the most
important pH and everything else is a
deriv all the other liquid. the pH of
the urine, pH of the sweat, pH of the
saliva, which are like derivatives of
the pH of the blood are going to be
alkaline. The body needs alkaline.
Alkaline represents electrons. It's all
about electrons. We've talked about that
before. Alkaline represents electrons.
Acid represents
stealing of electrons. Excess electrons
versus stealing of electrons. Acids
steal electrons.
Alkaline is like it's it's a surfet of
electrons. So you want to have
electronic energy in the blood and foods
you want to have not too much. You want
to have just enough and that's why the
pH is slightly alkaline.
Once you start getting into the
production of waste, acids or the wastes
are acidic. So acids are a sign that
you're not getting rid of waste. You're
producing too much waste. U things are
breaking down. So acids are indicative.
They're markers
for poor health. It's a sign that your
body is under duress or not detoxifying
appropriately or both. It could also be
a sign of building if you're healthy.
So, for example, after you come home
from the gym, you might be a slightly
more acidic or uh when you work out,
you can feel acid, lactic acid in your
muscles. Lactic acid, as it turns out,
acid is a growth element. Acids
stimulate growth.
Now, I just said that acids are a sign
of waste and then I said acids stimulate
growth. So, how does that work?
>> Well, you got to break down to rebuild,
right? You you um
>> right, the acids are a sign of breakdown
and the body's response to breakdown is
>> metabolism. Is that um
>> metabolism and yeah, and that and that's
really what it's all about. It's a b
catabolic anabolic balance. And you want
to be net anabolic.
If you're acidic, chronically acidic,
you're net catabolic.
If you're if you're taking care of
yourself though, that acid can be used
to convert it into growth. If you come
home and do your protein, for example.
>> So, if you're acidic and then you add
protein, that's a benefit. You're
saying?
>> Say that one more time.
>> If you're acidic, you just worked out
>> your muscles are acidic. That's
>> and you add not just protein but other
nutrients
but other nutrients um
>> because the acid is going to break down
those nutrients in that part of the
body.
>> Well, one of the things that happens
when you're breaking down when your
body's breaking down is it's releasing
nutrients. It's releasing substances.
You know, like if your bone breaks down,
you're releasing calcium. But that's not
what that's not that's not what we're
talking about here. Acid
tells the body it's under stress.
Acid signals stress. Acid signals
damage. Acid signal signals um a burden,
a heavy burden, extra work. When the
body senses acid, says there's lots,
there's some kind of stressor going on.
So what's the body's response to
stressors? If you're healthy, building
the body builds in response to
stressors. That's called hormesis. H O R
M S I S. It's also called
anti-fragility.
The body is ant. Have we ever talked
about anti-fragility?
>> Not that term, but the con
>> anti Yes. the concept anti-fragility.
Fragile systems like your iPhone, you
drop it, it's going to break.
Nonfragile systems like steel, you drop
it, it doesn't break.
An anti-fragile system, when you drop
it, it builds. It gets stronger. So
fragile breaks, non-fragile doesn't
break. Antifragile builds in response to
stress. The body is an anti-fragile
system. Hormesis is an example of
poisons stimulating activity, biological
activity. So a little bit of poison is a
good thing. A little bit of stress is a
good thing. When you produce a when
you're when you work out and you're have
more more acid, your blood is your blood
is more acidic, slightly more acidic.
You don't want to get too acid. Well,
>> that tells the body to grow. That tells
the body to build. When your muscles are
acidic, that signals growth. What's
that? Based on what you just said, it
sounds like you just made a commercial
for taking a vaccine.
>> How so? Oh, that's the way vaccines
that's kind of the logic of vaccines.
The problem with vaccines are they're
not as benign as pH or as, you know, as
acid, as hydrogen ions. Vaccines are
very, very complicated substances. Very
complicated. Way too complicated to just
be injected mindlessly into the body,
especially these new complicated ones.
Not only that, but ordinary vaccines,
they have to turn on the immune system.
And because they're not active really
strong enough to turn on the immune
system, they have to put extra poison in
there. Did you know that? They call them
adgivants like aluminum and squaline.
And these these adgiants assure that
you're going to have an immune reaction
because sometimes the antigen in the
vaccine is not strong enough to give you
an immune reaction. It's either
mitigate. It's either weakened or
attenuated or it's or is dead. So it
doesn't always trigger the immune
response you're looking for. just they
got to put extra poison in there to make
sure that your immune system is
activated.
So, no, I'm not vaccines are, you know,
there's probably there's probably a
certain amount of like if I was going to
Africa or South America, I'd probably
want a malaria vaccine. You know what
I'm saying? If there's if the choice was
malaria or protection from malaria, the
vaccine, but that doesn't mean I'd want
80. I think the average kid today gets
like 70 or 80 vaci vaccinations. Some
ridiculous amount. That's ridiculous.
I I it's a crazy number. I don't don't
quote me on the number, but it's a crazy
number of vaccinations.
>> If you were going to an area that that's
that's uh you know carries a high
mosquito virus
>> Yeah.
>> potential, would you just take more
vitamin C and zinc?
>> No, I would I would I'd get a I would
get the malaria vaccine probably.
>> There's no no recovering from malaria.
>> That's I think it's the most it's the
most deadly disease on the planet. I
think if I'm not mistaken,
no, I don't I look, I'm not polyianish
about drugs. I just think that most of
the time they're just they're not in the
patient's advantage. But I've talked
about pain pills. I mean, I
morphine. Let me tell you something. You
wouldn't want can you imagine how
surgery was done before pain before
anesthesia?
Literally, they would hold you down
while they saw your breast off or your
bone your leg off or whatever it was.
Can you imagine in World War in the
Civil War, you know, they used to have I
think they give you alcohol or ether or
something. No, there's times you need
drugs. For sure, for sure. For sure. For
sure. It's just that the overuse of
them, the craziness that the overuse of
them is just absurd. And it's not for
people, it's for companies.
Like what is this? Like Florida release
of Gates Mosquito. Oh, yeah. The Gates
mosquitoes. That's a good one. I I don't
know the exact maybe this person can
tell us about that but they they
genetically modified the mosquito to
like carry some anti- something medicine
in it and I I forgot what it was. Yeah.
Have you heard about this?
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's Keely that
mentioned that. I did hear about
something. Uh
>> I forgot what it was. It's some way of
inoculating everybody against a virus. I
don't know what it was against.
>> Yeah. you know,
>> so nobody gets sick anymore because
they've all been mod injected with GMO
mosquitoes,
>> you know. Um, but I mean throughout
history, you know, we've we've modified
certain things, you know, certain
>> not the way we do it today,
>> genetic modification has been going on
for centuries, thousands of years
probably.
>> Yeah.
>> That's how like I don't know, that's how
mules mules were. Mules are like a cross
between a donkey and a and a horse,
right? Right.
>> I think there's fruits like the tangelo,
you know, there's there's various fruits
that are combinations. Yeah, they've
been doing that grafting and and mixing,
you know, mixing the genetics of
different plants. They've been doing
that forever and and of animals,
livestock, but now we're doing it in a
completely different way in the
laboratory.
>> Absolutely. Uh
>> oh, who says this? Oh, wow.
>> That's Ruth Ellen mentioning because we
do get a lot of people who ask about Dr.
Wallak and Dr. Wallik has
>> he's doing well.
>> Paid his dues already.
>> H how many how many years ago was it
that you knew Dr. Kawick to be doing 300
seminars a year? How many years ago was
it?
>> He was probably doing that up until
maybe 2012 or I he fell like right
before COVID he fell and that's
>> I remember when he fell. I was I was a
listener coast to coast at the time.
>> Yeah. He stepped in a hole somewhere
like like a
>> stepped in a hole and rebar went through
his leg.
>> Yeah, he was in bad shape
>> for what year? But
>> 2019
>> something else might not have survived.
>> No, he lasted a while.
>> I think that happened in 2019.
>> Um, so he was doing up until then he was
probably doing 300 shows a year.
>> Certainly he was at the top of his game
doing shows 2017, 2018. I saw him I saw
him a whole bunch back in those years. I
can't believe that was 10 years ago
almost.
>> When was the first time you knew of him
to do a lot of shows a year? Was it
2000?
>> The very
>> No, the very beginning. When was it?
>> 98 97. That's when I started. That's
when I started. I I didn't know about
him until 98. 98 is when I first got my
first Dead Doctors Don't Lie tape. And
you know, like most everybody who heard
it was completely blown away.
>> Okay. So from 98 to let's say 2019.
What's that? 30 years.
>> What's that? 20 years. Wait.
>> Yeah. 20 years. 20 years.
>> 20 years.
>> 20 years or over 300 shows a year.
>> 6,000 shows. 6,000 shows.
>> I mean, come on.
>> I know. I know. He's got quite the
legacy.
>> Quite the legacy.
>> Live in impacting people live, you know.
>> Oh, yeah. He would do a talk for like
three three and a half hours and then at
the end he would stay up till like 3:00
in the morning answering questions
literally in the lobby at the hotel. He
would just stay he would stay up. He
wouldn't go to sleep. He just answer
everybody's questions.
>> I I remember I'm with him in uh in uh
California. We're we're at a show and
he's just looking at everybody else just
pretty much like Yeah, AJ, they're all
petered out.
>> They're all petered out. just like he's
just not, you know, and this. Okay, so
Kenya is asking.
>> Put Kenya on. I want to see I want to
see Kenya.
>> Kenya's on uh Rumble. She's is slippery
elm safe to take on a daily on on a
daily basis to protect your gut and help
digestion issues.
>> Sure. Slippery elm is one of those
mucilaginous kinds of herbs like mullen,
cold foot, marsh, malo, slippery elm.
Absolutely.
mucilaginous.
It's also it's it's just overall
slippery elm's just it's a great herb.
Um uh and I I I'm not big on herbal
medicine but there's certain herbs I
really like and slippery elm is one of
them. Uh yes to answer your question.
>> Okay, I'm going to let you go. These are
the people who have said that they have
heard of ple. So don't think that the
world doesn't know about Ple and this is
>> who he's not like Babe Ruth though.
>> No, he's not like Well, you got to
imagine that soccer is the world.
>> Soccer is not like base or maybe around
the world. I'll bet Ple around the world
is like that, but not in the United
States. I remember Ple because he played
for the New Jersey soccer team.
>> Oh, that was so late in his career.
>> Yeah. Well, I I I knew about him before,
but he was it was really big when he
played for New Jersey.
>> Yeah. So,
>> right,
>> we we got we gotta it'd be nice to to do
to and then Traders got a one, two.
Fantastic. Well, I I appreciate you very
much. And you know,
>> thank you, sir. We'll see you next I'll
see you Friday.
>> We're we're having a World Cup here in
New York, so I got to talk good about
soccer or otherwise it'll come.
>> All right. All right. I got that. Um,
hey, coast to coast tomorrow.
>> Coast to coast tomorrow night. What do
you know? Do you have a particular topic
that you'll be
>> No, he just he just he just I just wing
it.
>> Okay, folks.
>> If you want to listen to Ben on coast to
coast.com
for free and you're not a Coast to Coast
Insider, you can go to ksco.com
and hit the listen live button. And that
would be at um that is was it 1:00 a.m.
Eastern. Uh what time is it for you when
you're on?
>> It's 11 11 o'lock mountain. So it would
be 10 o'clock Pacific,
one o'clock Eastern.
>> That's right, folks. So, uh, make sure
you you go to kso.com and tune in and,
uh, listen for free to pharmacist Ben on
Coast to Coast AM where he is just going
to be winging it off the top of his
head, telling telling, uh,
>> the gospel and nutrition,
>> the gospel and nutrition and all the all
the great stuff. And, and Ben, we
appreciate you. Any thank you parting
words that you
>> Yes. Yes. No matter what your health
challenge is, people get on a supplement
program. Eliminate problem foods. Make
sure you're breathing correctly.
Practice and leverage
clean the blood. There's no such thing
as a chronic degenerative condition that
cannot be reversed. Believe it, leverage
it, and enjoy your life.
Look away.